aulas les gardiens du ciel et des
pirates sanguinaires ont le parchemin
qui mène à sony c'est vous qui devait
sauver l'oeuvre du dragon enfreignait de
retourner à l'alcôve se préparer on a
une chasse au trésor qui nous fait
enfants avant 25 ans certainement
les légendaires gardiens du ciel on a
enfin droit à un peu de respect
apparemment quelqu'un nous a devancé
c'est de la folie
on va trouver cette offre avant tout et
le mettre en sécurité dans un bon jour
bouille
désolé je croyais qu on y allait à 2-2
puis quand on y va à 2 pourquoi c'est
toujours le 3 quel droit de s'amuser
il est temps d'aller chercher l'enfant
n'a pu rattraper
ouais c'est écrit rien et la clique qui
osent envahir le nid du dragon d'or
qu'on vient vous aider à protéger votre
oeuf mais qu'ils se mettent sur mon
chemin et ils auront affaire à ça
attendez votre à tête serge et
paillettes c'est pas des paillettes
c'est une explosion
oui tu as raison on dirait des
paillettes